this week president biden laid out a
very ambitious goal he wants 70 of the
world's population to be vaccinated
against covet in the next year but for
many nations that is a huge challenge in
the tiny african kingdom of lesotho the
official death toll there is around 400
but it's thought to be much much higher
higher deborah powder traveled there to
see the difficulties firsthand
especially when it comes to rural
communities which just are very hard to
reach
as dawn breaks pilot matthew monson gets
ready for a busy day ahead he makes the
final checks
before flying health workers on the
pandemic front line to the most remote
parts of lesotho it's not called the
mountain kingdom for nothing but that
makes places like this really hard to
reach and often the weather is volatile
as well hampering efforts to get those
vaccines into arms
dr justin tsushir is supervising the
covert vaccine rollout from the skies
he's skeptical about achieving a 70
global vaccination rate within one year
the suggestion of president biden to
vaccinate 70 percent of population in
african continent
this can be really a big challenge
lesotho believes it will get enough
vaccines to inoculate its nearly 1.6
million adult population but acquiring
them is only half the battle sometimes
the challenge is how we can reach them
in the village of leba king only five
people have turned up for a shot one of
them is 69 year old kapigana mapondo so
it took you two hours to walk here two
hours
people have to cross mountains and
rivers to get to clinics donkeys are the
most common form of transport if you're
lucky enough to own one
our next stop is manamaning sometimes
the wind is so bad flying is impossible
but today there's a different
obstruction preventing us from touching
down
sure well that was a little bit of an
interesting landing we had to abort the
first one because there were too many
sheep on the runway just one of the
hazards of flying in the suture
but a hazardous landing is only the
start of the obstacles facing these
health workers we have to move out in
the village to find people from their
homes so instead of waiting for people
to come to the clinic they're taking the
vaccines to them but like so many
far-flung african regions the pace of
vaccinations is excruciatingly slow and
while wealthier nations roll out third
covert booster shots they remain
dangerously exposed to a looming fourth
wave
for cbs mornings debra patter lusutu